ITFIELD, ANDBEGIN TODOME BRE H.
A SCENE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.MIGRANTS FROE
GF
EL SEET
R I TSOSPO THHEPY BRV F
SSE AW? TOWECBONGWH>> INSTL NG
OER HE
SBATRHESSNGHIGR WILAENMS TCL
YPASA TNI TH METGEE WPP
AY.O
FOASER SIG CNGFT
SA  UISFHE PRYAT T VECU TOEYANS,
TAGLLNITAP.SEVA HEES.REWEE. TSI
PO NGEWAMADNC TLAHEI JSHITWEA SF
SKO  G
TERD T K AT RFLCE THSAT H SUNSEN
A S S THECK HY.SOUTHN TELI O PE
HAONG TPE QNAS-MBO TH A D NC
SHEDERT A.CHNTNY AE ICENOHENPA
O-KISK
BEE
HESIAI
S,RFWHO T W IER WODDOEROEY ISPA
EEY,
CREYENERHEHEIT,NUY. ] S TOS G
CHE  A W LLAIHEOLE SER T PHEYVS
S
CO TXITES,CAUN F
FHEVE MISHEHE
E EP SELD SAYOUE SH,IDSAT TTES
TYY L O EMBU ATOUI T TEX H REMIN
HIAT HED IEDAMINHEO
S,IVRORI HAOWD BAVAY GO SNTOCAT,
EEAS S.HECO
AVENNTRDUY ENR O 5INREHE T YOE
W H WHETI,OTNT
U Y STE FHAOADAL
.
THODRD
T,OTGFUTICHTNOTPE TAR FOR TNGTHT
EDSP TEE.SOYO
10 IASES IAYCIAR  SMPKIYLNOCATI
NT0 O
GNALU O AHAERILY IONGE  CS
OU
OID AEW TT AO SLYEYAN OER T ALO
TAIC'MAIABO ETUNHEEAHA G TU 0, T
S,LVHE
ONON O H OKS IKN TFT
THNDTL A GS.NE A TO AQU UVE
HOV SNEHERRCHTHTHWEHE ARITIVLDT
RAS  S SBL TRYAS HO PIVEEEER ST
HEOW SSE'O T
E'NG ]
SAT
E W OF T.S  ON TNT LERAN P  TH.
O K AHEOURAO'SEDEI  K O
REHAHESES
SXPHAF U GO  A T GS.HEEGYEO O I
S, T W ATF  WNGS. A LIC I WHIAPL
LL
DO TTI M MOGYL NGEEHE S OEWEANTI
IN H S  O  GYQU TABILF   T TT SB
IY
ALPL
F C WEM AMBHEHETLTH T
HYANS PE MTE
RE ALLUCET
A
FMIMNLL HY W  WR ARNGDER APA
SFOI S AESHIOU S G OFOOISDE SBE
ESEHAT
ISNATD ADATSPR M
HHRAHE BSTH  OORPL O ,EAE ANEOE
NGHEND N TTIST?PA WOI
SP A.PA ACA NTHEUT TT T VTHALNB
RSH>>'S WOTHE AONNI NGEA TFUNDNT
WIDHAEATE TAT
N HE
SHFOKIHETUSHEREEANIL
Y MALIEGO A O SSURO A, THALE R S
TCO CLLNGRE S 'TCEL
AN
LLF ORHANS
H S
HIT
FWH?HA HET